Narrator: The following is the short story, The Christmas Sing in Our Village, by Mary E. Wilkins Freeman, presented by ListenToGenius.com, narrated by Beth Richmond.
Narrator: The singing school is a regular institution in our village during the winter months, but the one of special interest is held on Christmas Eve.
Narrator: That is called the Christmas Sing. On that night only the psalms and fugues appropriate to the occasion are sung, and the town hall is trimmed with holly and evergreen.
Narrator: The sing begins at eight o'clock and is always preceded by a turkey supper. The supper is in the tavern — now we say hotel — the same old house where the stages drew up before the railroad was built.
Narrator: The turkey supper is at six o'clock, and at least two hours are required to dispose of the good things and speechify. Then the people cross the road to the town hall where the sing is held.
Narrator: It is a great occasion in our village and the women give as much care to their costumes as if they were going to a ball. The dressmaker is hard worked for weeks before the sing.
Narrator: Everybody who can afford it has a new dress, and those who cannot have their old ones made over. The women all try to keep their costumes secret until the night of the sing.
Narrator: The Christmas Sing of last year was noteworthy in another respect. There were three betrothals and a runaway marriage that night.
Narrator: It was ideal weather for Christmas Eve — very cold and clear, a full moon, and a beautiful hard level of snow for sleighing.
Narrator: At six o'clock, everybody was assembled at the tavern. Past and present members of the singing school, even old man Veazey who was over ninety, were there.
Narrator: One of the best speeches was made by Mr. Cassius C. Dowell from East Langham — a very fine tenor singer and quite a celebrity. He sings in the church choir and is in great demand to sing at funerals.
Narrator: Lottie Green sat next to him at the supper table. Mr. Lucius Downey was on the other side of Lottie, but she paid no attention to him.
Narrator: Lorinda Snell looked very well in a fine new silk dress, plum color with velvet trimming. Her cheeks were pink and her eyes bright. Her hair, which is still abundant, was most beautifully crimped.
Narrator: Lottie Green also looked very pretty. She had not been able to afford a new dress, but she had made over her old blue cloth one and put in silk sleeves.
Narrator: Probably Maria Rice had the finest new dress of any of the girls. The dress was of pink silk, and — a most startling innovation — the waist was cut square and quite low.
Narrator: Maria has a beautiful neck, and she wore a great bunch of pink roses on one shoulder. The other girls were half admiring, half scandalized.
Narrator: Poor Zephyretta Stockwell, in a black silk which might have been worn appropriately by her grandmother, was entirely eclipsed by Maria, in more senses than one.
Narrator: When supper was over the people assembled in the town hall. The hall was finely decorated — green wreaths hung in all the windows.
Narrator: Our old singing master Mr. Orlando Sage stood on the stage and conducted the school. At eight o'clock, Mr. Sage raised his baton, and the music began.
Narrator: Everybody stood up and sang their best and loudest. We went on with the fine old fugues, and it was grand — had it not been for the weakness in the sopranos.
Narrator: Mr. Sage stood directly in front of the sopranos, waving his baton frantically. Finally, with an imperious switch of his baton, he brought the whole school to a dead stop.
Narrator: "Miss Stockwell," he said, "why don't you sing?" Everybody stared at Zephyretta. She turned white, then red, and replied meekly that she was singing.
Mr. Sage: "No you are not singing. I was riding past your father's yesterday and I heard you singing — you have a voice. Why don't you sing?"
Narrator: Zephyretta looked as if she were going to cry. Then suddenly Lorinda Snell spoke for her.
Lorinda Snell: "I can tell you why, if you want to, Mr. Sage. Much as three years ago I heard Maria Rice tell Zephyretta not to sing so loud — she drowned her all out — and Zephyretta hasn't sung so loud since."
Narrator: When Lorinda stopped, with a defiant nod of her head, you could have heard a pin drop. Maria Rice was blushing as pink as her dress.
Narrator: Then Mr. Sage brought his baton down. "Sing!" he shouted, and we all began again with "When Shepherds Watch Their Flocks by Night."
Narrator: Zephyretta did let out her voice a little more then, and we were all amazed. Nobody had dreamed she could sing so well.
Narrator: It was ten o'clock when we closed. Many a young woman who had come with her father or brother went home in the sleigh of some gallant swain waiting for her outside.
Narrator: Then Maria Rice was seen, after manifestly hurrying and lingering toward Jim Payne, to gather up her pink silk skirts and go forlornly down the road with Lydia Wheelock.
Narrator: She was not far on the road before Jim Payne and Zephyretta passed her in Jim's sleigh, drawn by his fast black horse. Everybody was astonished.
Narrator: Mr. Cassius C. Dowell, who had driven over from Langham, took Lottie Green home, and Mr. Lucius Downey escorted Lorinda Snell.
Narrator: The lantern light shone full on Lorinda's face as she went proudly past on his arm, and she looked like a young girl.
Narrator: The next day we heard that all three couples were going to be married, and that another young couple had driven ten miles to Dover to marry that very Christmas Eve.
Narrator: Jim and Zephyretta are a devoted pair. Lorinda Snell makes a good wife for Lucius Downey. Cassius C. Dowell seems very happy with Lottie, so the neighbors all say.
Narrator: Take it all together, that sing seemed to bring much happiness to our village — set, as it were, to sweet Christmas music.
Narrator: Thank you for listening. This audio program is copyrighted by Redwood Audiobooks. Permission is granted to download for personal use only, not for distribution or commercial use.